هاجمت 31 طائره مسيره اوكرانيه خلال الليل
مناطق بجرود وبرانس وكورس الروسيه
المحاذيه لاوكرانيا وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
قالت انها تصدت لها واسقطت دون وقوع
اصابات حاكم بريانسك الكسندر بوجو ماز
افاد بان كيف استخدم ذخائر عنقوديه ضد
اربع مقاطعات في منطقته ما ادى الى دمار
جزئي في مساكنه
ومبان كما اعلنت الوزاره في وقت لاحق عن
تصدي القوات الجويه الروسيه لعمليه انزال
بحري نفذتها قوه اوكرانيه استخدمت زورقا
سريعا وثلاث درجات مائيه كيف لم تعلق على
ما سبق الرئيس الاوكراني فلودمير زيلينسكي
زار الجبهه الشرقيه تحديدا في المنطقه
التي تضم بلدتي كوبيانسك وليمان التين
يستهدفه الجيش الروسي مؤخرا واكد من هناك
على اهميه صمود الجبهه الشرقيه من المهم
للغايه صمود خاركيف على الرغم من كل شيء
صمود يساعد في الحفاظ على شرقنا باكمله
قويا مدينه الفخر والاشراق ستظل دائما
مدينه القوه لاوكرانيا لاوروبا
باكملها كما قام زيلينسكي بتكريم الجنود
وتفقد دبابات ليوبارد اثنان ومركبات مشاه
قتاليه كان قد قدمها الغرب الى كيف من اجل
هجومها المضاد والتي شاركت في المعارك في
قطاع كوبيانسك